and then if you read some of the stuff
they're doing uh with the James Webb
Telescope and them being able to look
for signs of life
on other planets it's quite fascinating
and you know recent stuff I read say
they think in 20 years they will
so
it's actually quite encouraging to think
I've almost dream of mine like in our
lifetimes that we discover Life on
another planet
yeah especially if it's intelligent life
I've been talking to a lot of biologists
and a lot of folks I imagine there's
life everywhere out there the numbers
are would say so yes the challenging
question is what it looks like and how
much of it is intelligent so a lot of
biologists tell me the big the big
difficult leap is from the precarious to
the eukaryotes so like the the complex
life it could be that a lot of our
universe is just filled with bacteria
I believe if if I'm understanding it
right that there's two ways they're
going to look at planets when they can
look at you know they can read hey this
planet has this kind of gas they can now
look at the ones that are created by
potential life forms and then the ones
that are created the byproducts of
Industry so there's only certain ones
that are created if you have a society
there
um and that they can start looking on
these types of in these types of star
systems and these planets but it takes a
lot of time because you have to book
time in that telescope you have to like
look at that planet over a long period
of time but
in theory given enough time given the
amount of space out there
um
we would find one
that would be a cool thing in this short
life of ours to find out
definitively that there is an an
industrial intelligent civilization out
there
before you contact them so like die end
your life
not knowing the rest of the story but
just know that it's out there that's a
cool and then if you have kids be like
well this one's on you
uh F this I'm out and I'm fascinated by
what it would do
to the way I think in a positive way the
way Humanity thinks about itself here
like no there's there is a definitively
other life out there I mean both things
if there isn't life out there
that's also a huge responsibility both
are super exciting
for a loan it's super exciting because
there's a responsibility to preserve
whatever special thing we have going on
here this uh
whether you call it the flame of
Consciousness or whether it's
Consciousness or intelligence that's the
special thing preserve it have it expand
but if there's others out there
I mean that like that Sparks that drive
for exploration
of reaching out to the stars and meeting
them
most of them probably want to kill us
so but luckily we have the
military-industrial complex on Earth
that builds bigger and better weapons
all the time space force it will both
protect us and destroy all our enemies
[Laughter]
uh uh this this is 100 a video game
we're living in